All
right. All right. Thank you for joining
me on this episode of the Gospel Truth.
I'm your host, Warren Wilson, and we
have a another debate, as you know, uh,
and I'm excited for this one. Uh, we're
going to be jumping into some, uh, uh,
7th day Adventist doctrine, uh,
Leviticus 16 and [music] the scapegoat,
and we're going to be going through
that. And I have Miles, Christian with
me, and I have Keith Bowman with me, and
we're going to be talking about that.
But before I bring these guys in, I do
want to encourage you to subscribe, hit
that notification bell on the Gospel
Truth, so you can stay in the loop with
the God truth that's going on. You want
to miss out on any shows, [music]
any debates, any interviews, anything,
right? You don't want to miss out any
video videos I upload. The only way you
can stay locked in is if you hit that
not subscribe and hit that notification
bell so you don't miss out on any shows
that are coming up here in the future.
All right. All this content is not only
on YouTube, but Facebook, Twitter,
Instagram, and Tik Tok. So, have you yet
to start following the Gospel of Truth
on those platforms? Make sure you do so
so you don't miss out anything. You
know, I do little rebuttal videos on Tik
Tok and I post those rebuttal videos on
Instagram and sometimes on Facebook
depending what exactly the context is,
[music] but I post those videos on there
and I post them on YouTube as well. So,
make sure you follow those social media
platforms and follow on those platforms
as well. Also, all this all this content
is on podcast as well, iTunes, Google
Play, Stitcher, Spotify. to make sure
that you are following and subscribing
on those podcasts, whatever one you
choose [music] to listen from. All
right. Uh, as always, I have several
shows that are coming up here in the
future that I want you guys to be aware
of. Uh, coming up, uh, is Open Theism
Biblical? Jonathan Singleton, Chris
Fiser. You may know Chris Fiser from
past debates if you are avid debate
watcher on YouTube. Uh, in the
theological realm, uh, he's some
debates. John Jonathan Singleton I
believe is a newcomer to the to the
debating ring. I believe he's a former
open theist. So these type of debates
are very fun to watch. Uh people who are
familiar with the was a part of that
formally and able to jump in and debate
that subject they now disagree with.
Those type of debates are always fun. So
that's coming up here. Hope you're
looking forward to it. Next one I have
is David Palman versus Leo. Does the
Christian God exist? Atheist versus
Christian. So this is a good one.
Hopefully you guys are looking forward
to this one. After that, I have a uh uh
Islam versus Christian, a Muslim versus
Christian, let's say. I have a black
doctor versus Mansour. The black
doctor's name is also Jeremiah Short.
And he's going to be debating on here.
Does the Bible teach the deity of
Christ? So, this is going to be a fun
debate. So, make sure you looking
forward to this one. After that, I have
an interview with Dr. James Anderson.
Determinism and open theism. Yes,
opaththeism is of subject a lot and over
the next couple weeks. So, hope you guys
are looking forward to it. It should be
a fun interview. Uh, also once again,
we're doing a fundraiser. I'm trying to
buy some road audio equipment and video
equipment. So, if you care to assist in
these efforts of raising funds, please
uh make sure you are checking out the
links in the description of this video
so you could look for further
instructions on how to support the
ministry and his efforts. All right,
that said, um, like I said, I have a
couple guys on here. Uh, Keith is a
newcomer to the Gospel Truth, and Miles
has been on twice. I think Miles debated
Anthony Burrell. He's also a 7-day
Adventist. And, uh, it's guy by the name
of the Snake is Right. Um, you guys,
some of you guys, once again, if you're
avid debate watcher on YouTube, you
probably heard of the Snake is right
guy. Uh, he's on Mod Debate and other
debate platforms. But yeah, Miles
debated him and uh so this is his third
goround on the gospel truth and once
again Keith this is his first time on
the gospel truth and we're going to be
talking about some scapegoat Leviticus
16 see what they be talking about. All
right, see what they talking about but
we going to bring these guys in. Let's
let these guys introduce themselves so
you guys will get to know them a little
bit. How you doing fellas? How's it
going?
Good. Doing real good.
Awesome. Awesome man.
All right, man. I'm glad you guys uh
join me. Uh, I don't know if you guys um
I'm talking to the audience, but
obviously I'm be talking about you guys.
So, audience, I don't know if you guys
saw Miles uh last two debates. I think
it was done in his home office, I
believe it is, or his room. And he did
it on his cell phone, right? So, I want
you guys to really when he give his
introduction, I want you guys to really
check out his studio, man.
It's lit. It's dope, man. It's clean,
you know. I think his camera's better
than mine, man. You know, I got my
little uh my little Ricky Dink desktop
camera here, but I think Miles on point,
man. It ain't Keith. You don't yourself,
Keith. I ain't trying to give Miles all
the props
on set and everything.
No, man. This is just uh my computer
camera, so I don't have anything going
on. But my I do have a a studio setup. I
just I'm not using it tonight because I
figured I wouldn't be looking at you
guys' eyes if I was using it.
Oh, okay. Cool, man. It's all good.
That's kind of debates I like, man. The
eye contact make it serious, man. So,
good stuff, man. It's all good. But, as
I said, man, I'm going give you guys a
chance to introduce yourselves to the
audience, man, before we jump into this
debate. So, start with Miles, man. Go
ahead and give a quick introduction to
yourself, man.
Yeah. So, uh, welcome. Like you said,
I've been on the channel before. Marlin,
thanks for having me. Uh, I am a former
third generation 7th Day Adventist. I am
now not an Adventist and I run a YouTube
channel called Answering Adventism.
All right. All right. Cool. Nice and
piffy uh introduction. I like that. All
right. Keith, you're up next for your
introduction. Go ahead. Tell them what
you do, man.
My name is Keith Bowman. Um
I uh was kind of um came to become a 7th
Day Adventist when I was 12 years old
and uh stuck with it. um had a period of
time basically during college where I
really uh struggled with Adventism.
Became a an Adventist pastor. Went to my
conference president, told him I wasn't
an Adventist anymore. Didn't believe any
of the doctrine.
um and then just kept studying and uh
actually came around to uh believe
believe 7th day a Adventist's beliefs.
So uh I ended up uh being a pastor again
and here I am um 20 years later.
All right. All right. Thank you guys
once again for joining me on this
episode. So we are going to get into
this debate. This is, you know, we don't
get to debate uh 7-day Adventist
doctrine a lot, man. Um I don't know
what it is. Maybe you can fill me in,
Keith, but why is it that they you know,
a lot of Seven Day Adventists are like
jumping at the opportunity for debating.
I don't I guess I don't I'm not really
understanding it.
That That's a great question. You know,
I actually watch a lot of anti-adventist
videos and read a lot of uh commentaries
and other works out there. I attend
ETSs, you know, every other year and
stuff. And and what I've noticed is just
kind of the reception that Adventists
get from other Christians is very much,
hey, you guys are a cult. You're not
part of the conversation. I think that
kind of puts a bad taste in the mouth of
like Adventists being like, well, uh,
you know, if we do debate things,
there's not there's not going to be this
like kind of brotherly Christian
attitude towards each other. It's It's
more like, "Hey, you're the devil and I
need to exercise you from uh the
[clears throat] Christian community." I
think that's the reason if I'm being
honest.
All right. Well, obviously there's some
disagreement here. You know, there's
some disagreement, but we're going to
have a good conversation, a good debate
uh on this convers. So, I'm excited for
this one. Um and so, the topic of
today's debate is Satan the scapegoat of
Leviticus 16. All right. So, Keith,
you're arguing affirmative debate. ize
your argony and negative in this debate.
So, we're going to start off with
15-minute opening statements by each
party. Then, we're going to flow to I
believe a uh
30 minute cross X, right? Both of you
get 15 minutes each to uh sort of if you
want to cross X, if you just want to
present, have you guys want to double
that out, right? Uh then we're going to
have some fiveminute closings and then
we're going to have some Q&A from the
audience. Sounds good.
Sounds great.
All right, Keith, you're up first and
you can share your screen.
Well, um before I share my screen, I'm
I'm just going to read a little bit.
I've actually kind of written my opening
statement out. So, uh to make sure it
was 10 minutes when we were going to do
10 minutes, but uh I'll work it up to
15. So, here we go. Are you ready?
All right. Before you start, Keith, once
you get to the point where you want to
share your screen, I'll stop the time to
give you time to for your screen. Share
it to go through and then we'll restart
your time because I don't want you
to use your time up trying to share the
screen. You know what I mean?
Okay. You know what? I'll just go ahead
and share it. That way, we don't have to
worry about about doing that. In fact,
so uh you can see my notes. Um you guys
can read along with me. Uh, and I think
the value of this is I've put some some
links down at the bottom that uh you can
feel free to look up in in your own
time. Um, but I'm going to go ahead and
start reading. You ready for me, Marlon?
Yep. Go ahead. I'll start your time. You
begin to speak.
Okay. [snorts] Seventh day Adventists
believe in substitutionary atonement. We
believe that Jesus died on our behalf
and offered himself up as a sacrifice
while bearing our sins upon himself. We
believe that he suffered the guilt,
shame, and death, the second death that
we deserved so that we might receive the
guilt-free, shamefree life that he
deserved. We believe that Christ is the
propitiation or mercy seat for the whole
world according to 1 John 2:2. So that
what he suffered was not limited to the
just to just the elect but even those
who will never receive God's gift of
grace. In this way Christ has abundantly
provided grace for everyone and made the
ultimate s resulting in peace through
his blood upon the cross according to
also Colossians 1:20. This is very much
like most of our Christian brothers and
sisters. Apart from whether atonement
was limited to the elect or acquired for
the whole world, most would see the
above concept is very orthodox. To be
more specific about 7th Day Adventists,
our views are mostly Methodists in
relationship to sotiology. And those
links at the bottom, I would highly
recommend that you check those out. just
their Wikipedia links on Methodism and
Wesleyan uh theology. As free will
Armenian Protestants,
we believe that God makes a full 100%
effort to bring all to repentance, but
humans have been given the gift of free
will that allows them to respond to
offer. They may choose to accept or
reject Christ's work of atonement on
behalf of them. But like Methodists and
unlike those who believe in a once-saved
always always saved salvation. We
believe work of atonement is an
unfolding work rather than a finished
work. What do I believe that you can
choose to walk away from Christ after
you have received salvation? Your free
will doesn't end upon your initial
reception of God's grace.
Evidence for this is throughout the New
Testament as it uses very important
conditional clauses, uh, words like if
in Colossians 1:23 and Hebrews 3:6. Look
those up on your own time. and calls for
patient endurance in Hebrews 10:36
encouraging the saved not to draw back
to destruction assuming the possibility
the to SDAs this means that we see the
sacrifice of Christ entirely providing
for the work of atonement but unfolding
as a process over time we don't believe
it is limited to the events of Jesus's
life death and resurrection on earth but
rather it is interact interacting with
individual people in history, with
corporate humanity in phases, and even
with the angels and other potential
non-early beings. To quote Ephesians
1:10, that in the dispensation of the
fullness of times, he might gather
together in one all things in Christ,
both which are in heaven and which are
on earth in him. Atonement to Adventists
process by which God is purging the
universe of the stains of evil, sin, and
death, and bringing all of his creation
back into unity in Christ. This backdrop
is important to begin with because it
emphasizes that we believe in more than
simply a penal model of satisfying
either God and or his law. We expand
atonement to include cleansing,
transformation,
growth, vindication and reconciliation
of the entire community of life in the
universe. We call this meta narrative
the great controversy and it is largely
built from how we understand scripture
in relation to the old testament
tabernacle and the new test fulfillments
of those types or models. In brief, the
interpretation of the majority of the
Christian community sees atonement as a
singular function, which is to cover or
make atonement for the sins of the elect
in a legal way through the perfect life,
substitutionary death, and righteous
resurrection of Christ. In short,
Adventists would agree with this.
However, while the majority of the
Christian community interprets all the
events of the Old Testament tabernacle
to be fulfilled in that short period of
Christ's time on earth, after which he
sits at the right hand of the father
until his enemies are made his foottool,
we see different functions of the Old
Testament tabernacle having fulfillments
at different periods of time throughout
history. We see Christ's work of
atonement as an unfinished and not
complete until sin, evil, and death are
eradicated from the universe. We believe
that Christ is continuing to do a work
of intercession found in Hebrews 7:25,
not just sick. Allow me to zoom in on
the particulars at this point. In the
Adventist interpretation, Christ's
sacrifice was performed once and never
needs to be performed against again.
Christ is the fulfillment of every Old
Testament sacrificial offering ever
offered. We believe Hebrews 9 makes that
very clear. We believe that Christ's
perfect and complete offering made him
fit to serve as humanity's high priest
where he ever lives to make intercession
for those who come to God. Hebrews
7:25-28.
It is Christ's very sacrifice that made
him fit to enter heaven, present himself
to the father, John 2017. Inaugurate the
tabernacle in heaven, Hebrews 9:10. And
begin upon the work of mediating the new
covenant. Hebrews 8. First in the holy
place, he mediates this covenant. and re
we'll get into this a little bit more
later, but Revelation 1 12 and 13 41 and
5 and you can read all of those and
later in the most holy place. Um, this
brings us to the topic for today, the
sanctuary in Leviticus 16. Is Satan the
scapegoat of Leviticus 16? To answer
that question, I'd like to provide you
with four proofs. The term goat number
one is not in scripture. The original
use was meant to say the goat that
escaped.
Um, the term has evolved to indicate a
person who is punished for the sins of
others. Adventists don't believe Satan
is punished for other people's
responsibility. And I I just want to be
really clear about that because
everybody like seemingly for some reason
accuses us of thinking that that Satan
dies uh uh as a substitute for our sins.
And we don't believe that. Adventists
don't believe that Satan is punished for
other people's responsibility. They
believe that Satan is only punished for
his own culpability in causing others to
sin, including Israel. The term
scapegoat is a rather modern given to
the goat that has changed meanings since
it was first used in 1530 by William
Tinddale. When Tinddale used the term,
he meant it to mean the escapegoat,
which is in line with the idea conveyed
in the Septuagent. For those who don't
know, that's the Greek version of the
Old Testament, not the Hebrew version of
the Old Testament. And the Latin
Vulgate, which is basically a first few
centuries, they they made uh a Latin
version of of the Bible. that they
translated this goat as the goat that
departs or the goat that is sent out.
It's misleading to think that this goat
is a goat that takes your place. The
actual word used in the Bible is not at
all associated with the term scapegoat.
The word is aazel. It does not mean
scapegoat. To be fair, no one knows what
this term means. You can read any
commentary and they'll all tell you that
nobody knows what this term means. There
are at least four ways that this can be
translated and most commentaries will
note all four of these ways. It could
mean the goat that departs as was
already said above. It could be a demon
in the woods according to the apocryphal
book first Enoch and I'll say more about
that later probably. It could be the
goat for entire removal. It could also
be the goat for the strong or or rugged
one, which is what I believe that it
refers to. Leviticus 16 puts the two
goats side by side and they cast lots
over them. God assigns their identities.
One goat for the Lord and one goat for
Aazel or for in my view the strong
rugged mountain. according to verse 8 of
Leviticus 16. Why would I the
interpretation of Aazazelle is strong
rugged mountain? Well, the reason I
believe that is because when the
rabbitic Jews um now these are the Jews
that were uh uh mostly following the
time of Christ. Um after AD70, the
rabbitic Jews were writing down their
practices and procedures so that they
wouldn't be lost after the temple was
destroyed in AD.70. Uh you you may be
familiar there's a number of books that
they wrote. One of them is called the
Mishna. They wrote the meaning of Aazel
in the Mishna around the the 2n century
AD for that verse and that goat. Okay.
Uh they claimed that the goat was called
the goat for the strong rugged mountain
where they would eventually kick the
goat off in the wilderness.
Uh the goat for Aazelle is not
sacrificed. Very important. The goat of
the Lord is said to be an offering for
sin or purggation. Another word for
cleansing, purge, to purge something.
According to verse 9, that goat is what
purges, according to Leviticus, the most
holy place, the holy place, the altar,
and the people. The other goat is never
mentioned to do any of those things.
Jacob Mgrim, who is a Jew, uh, a
modern-day Jew, amongst numerous others,
points out that the goat of the Lord is
an offering on behalf of the people as a
substitute for their sin. Well, the goat
for Azazelle is a purification ritual
that removes evil from the camp and is
nonsacrificial.
Very important. The goat wasn't
sacrificed and Jews have never seen that
goat to be a sacrificial substitute for
uh the the community. Number three,
Jesus died for the sins of humanity. He
does not suffer for all of eternity. Uh
this is a uniquely Christian one that
I'm going to be addressing. The goat for
Aazel is released into the wilderness
alive. Numerous nonadventist Christians
have wrestled with the implication of
this. If this goat represents Christ and
one believes in what we call ect, ect is
eternal conscious torment. This is the
belief that says that uh God will
torture or torment or allow it, however
you view it. uh those who don't make it
to heaven, the non-elect, uh the fallen,
uh he will torture them for all of
eternity,
and they they won't lose consciousness
because of the pain. They will be
conscious throughout the entire
experience. Now uh these com combined
beliefs the belief in ect and the belief
that the scapegoat is Christ imply that
Christ began to suffer has been
suffering and will continue to suffer
torment for all of eternity uh because
this goat is sent into the wilderness
and not sacrificed to death.
[clears throat]
And number four, the best New Testament
demonstration of fulfillment of the Day
of Atonement ritual blatantly identifies
Satan as the goat for Aazelle.
This is found in Revelation 20:es 1-3.
Um, and I'm going to talk more about
this and when I get into the main
arguments a little bit later, but just
to give you a brief intro, Revelation is
a covenant book that reveals the
fulfillment of both the feasts of the
Lord and the tabernacle services. It
actually follows the high priest through
the first apartment rituals in the first
part of the book and then it transitions
to the second apartment rituals in the
second part of the book. The first
apartment rituals are found in
Revelation 11:12 and13
uh where Jesus is among the candlesticks
the manora uh chapters 4 and 5 where
Jesus is seen as the slain lamb which
reminds us of his sacrifice upon the
altar. He's also said to uh be present
in the entire world which reminds us of
the showbread or the bread of the
presence. Uh in chapter 5 I believe it's
verse 6. Um in chapter 83 says that he's
offering incense at the golden altar.
And in chapter 9 verse 13 it says that
the horns are speaking. Um the horns are
where they would put some of the blood
on the golden altar when they would
bring in the blood from the sacrifice
for sin. Um you know when people would
confess sins over a lamb and they would
catch the blood and they would bring it
in and they would sprinkle it in the
most sorry not the most holy the holy
place and put some on the horn. The
second apartment rituals are found in
Revelation 11:19 where it says in
Revelation 11:19 that you could see into
the Naos, the very very uh room or
apartment where God dwells and you could
see the ark of the covenant. Um there in
chapter 15, it uses identical language
to Leviticus 16:27. Um in chapter 20:es
1-3, we find the story line of the goat
of Aazelle. uh where it it follows the
exact uh line of thinking of the day of
atonement um where where basically a
strong man uh binds up the goat for Aza
and carries him into the wilderness and
releases him. That's Revelation 20
11-15. And finally, chapter 21 where
there is a banquet that is hosted by the
high priest to celebrate the fact that
he was successful in his work of the day
of atonement and uh purging evil from
the camp and that he did not die in the
presence of God. The equivalent to the
goat for Aazelle ritual is found in
Revelation chapter 20 and Satan is
explicitly the goat. Thank you.
All right. Thank you, Keith, for that
opening. And so, Miles, you're up next
for your 50-minute opening. And I will
start your time. You begin to speak.
[snorts]
All right. Thanks so much, Marlin.
Thanks for uh thanks as always for
having me. Keith, thanks for being here.
Uh simply put, and I'm sure Keith is
already aware of this, I'm going to be
defending that Jesus Christ is the
blessed scapegoat that bore our sins in
his body. 1 Peter 2:24, who just like
the scapegoat was taken outside of the
camp with the sins placed on him.
Hebrews 13:10-13.
And just like the scapegoat that bore
the guilt of the people, the Lord Jesus
Christ was the guilt offering for us.
Isaiah 53:10. Just like the scapegoat
that was sanctified, meaning set aside,
to have judgment pronounced over it, so
Jesus was sanctified, John 10:36, to
have judgment pronounced over him by
Pontius Pilate. Matthew 27:19. only
Jesus Christ and he alone fulfills all
of the necessary requirements of not
just the scapegoat but all the laws and
requirements for the offerings and
sacrifices. So as we examine if Satan is
typified in the scapegoat, I want the
audience to pay close attention to the
scapegoat's role and function and the
logical conclusion of Keith's position.
regardless of which argument he decides
to present, which we heard uh of which
there are many. The point that must be
proven is that Satan can fulfill the
requirements of the scapegoat, which we
heard nothing about. It's also important
to note that to fully grasp tonight's
debate topic, one has to have a general
understanding of the SDA church's
teaching regarding the investigative
judgment and the heavenly sanctuary. Due
to time constraints, a thorough
explanation of this doctrine is not
possible. But I have to give a flyover
explanation as this is the underlying
foundation of the debate. If Jesus isn't
currently doing what the Adventist
church claims that he is, then by
necessity, the idea of Satan being the
antitypical scapegoat collapses. So for
the sake of the audience, here's a brief
overview of the teaching that's a little
more granular than Keith went. They
teach that there is a sanctuary in
heaven identical to that of the earthly
only resurrected by God not by human
hands. They claim that in 1844 Jesus
entered the most holy place of this
sanctuary for the first time that prior
to this Christ was only in the holy
place doing a work of daily
ministration. They see Jesus as doing
the identical work of the Levitical
ironic priesthood but in heaven not on
earth. The Levitical day of atonement
was a type of the work that Jesus would
do in the heavenly which is the
antitype. They tell us that this work of
investigative judgment is the final
phase of Christ's atoning ministry prior
to the second advent. That is to say,
the atonement is not complete until this
work of investigation is finalized. As
Keith said, the claim is that in this
judgment, the record books of sin are
opened and the lives of all who've
professed faith come up in review before
God. Be uh beginning with the first
human generation, Jesus presents the
cases of each successive generation and
closes with the living. Every name is
mentioned and every case is closely
investigated. Some names are accepted
and some names rejected. Anyone who has
sins remaining upon the books of record,
whether unconfessed or forgotten. Their
names will be blotted out of the book of
life and the record of their good deeds
will be erased from the book of God's
remembrance. They say that just like in
the typical service where the high
priest made atonement for Israel and
came forth to bless the congregation, so
Christ at the close of his work as
mediator will appear to bless his
waiting people with eternal life. As the
priest in removing the sins from the
sanctuary, confess them upon the head of
the scapegoat, so Christ will also place
all of these sins upon Satan, the
originator and instigator of sin. Just
as the scapegoat bore the sins of Israel
and was sent away, Jesus will place them
upon Satan, who in the execution of the
judgment must bear the final penalty.
The scapegoat was sent away into a land
not inhabited, never to come again into
the congregation of Israel. So will
Satan be forever banished from the
presence of God and his people and he'll
be blotted from existence in the final
destruction of sin and sinners. Now I
know that was a lot but that was a
summation of the doctrine as a whole. So
you can see where the scapegoat fits
into all of this. This entire system of
theology can be thought of like a chain.
If any of the theological links break
any doctrines downchain from the broken
link are also falsified. So in the
interest of time tonight I'm going to
focus on two links in this chain. But I
want the viewer to know that there are
many more. The first broken link is the
idea that Jesus entered the most holy
place in heaven in 1844 for the first
time. Without this, the idea of an
investigative judgment is falsified.
Thus, their scapegoat teaching is also
after all, if Christ is not in heaven
doing what the Adventists claim because
he's already dealt with sin in its
entirety at the cross and he promises
that in the new covenant he remembers
our sins no more and eternal life is
already ours, then it makes no sense to
say that uh sin still has to be dealt
with to then be transferred to Satan.
And the second broken link is the
scapegoat teaching itself. If Satan
doesn't meet the qualifications that the
law required of the scapegoat, he can't
be the antitype. So the burden of proof
lies on our friend Keith to demonstrate
two things. One, that Jesus entered the
most holy place in heaven for the first
time in 1844. And two, that Satan meets
the qualifications for the scapegoat, of
which there are many. Regarding the
first point, there's many reputations,
but the one that I'm going to present is
found in Hebrews 9:8 and Hebrews 10:1
19-20. Hebrews 9:8 tells us that the way
into the most holy place is not yet open
to us as long as the first apartment is
still standing. the first apartment is
the holy place. He then tells us in
Hebrews 9:10-1 19 or uh Hebrews 10:19-20
that believers do have a way to enter
into the most holy place and it's by the
blood of Jesus. This means that the
first apartment, the holy place, is no
longer standing because a way has been
opened for us to enter into the presence
of God which is by the blood of Jesus.
So there's no way that Jesus was only
ministering in the first apartment for
18800 years because the first apartment
isn't standing anymore. That is unless
Keith wants to say that the book of
Hebrews was written after 1844. There's
no way to make this work. As to the
second point, Satan doesn't meet the
qualifications required of the
scapegoat. We heard nothing about that
in his opening. Leviticus says that all
animal offerings and sacrifices had to
be blemishfree. Leviticus 4:23,
Deuteronomy 17:1. And while it may not
have been a sacrifice, the scapegoat was
a offering. This is true of all the
animals used in the Levitical Day of
Atonement ceremony. Both the Lord's goat
and the scapegoat are no exception to
needing to be blemish free. We're told
in Leviticus 16:5 that the two goats,
this is the key, folks, functioned as a
singular sin offering. Meaning both were
required for sin to be atoned for and
taken away. Leviticus 16:10. The
sacrificed goat alone did not complete
the sin offering. Fundamentally, the
only difference between these two goats
was whichever one the lot fell on.
That's it. They were identical. The lot
that fell on the goat deemed the Lord's,
was sacrificed, typifying the punishment
for sin, which is death. And the second
goat, the scapegoat, was set aside,
sanctified to then have the blood of the
slang goat placed onto it, symbolic of
it bearing the sins and guilt, and was
then taken outside the camp to
foreshadow the sins of the people being
taken away from them. What is
accomplished then is more than just
payment for sin. The ritual makes use of
two animals to show different features
of this unique sin offering. One animal
died as a type of payment so that
justice would be satisfied. the other
remained alive to demonstrate the
complete removal of sin from view.
Without this aspect, our sins could be
paid for but still plague us as the
payment of sin solves only part of the
problem. So with this in view, Keith,
you need to demonstrate that even if we
grant 1844 that Satan meets the
qualifications of the scapegoat. Is
Satan blemish free? Is Satan identical
to Christ who the Adventists say was
typified by the Lord's goat? Is Satan a
part of the atonement with Christ?
Leviticus 16:10 plainly says the
scapegoat had atonement made on it. This
is the logical conclusion of the
Adventist position. That's why people
think and wonder that because that's
what the verse says. Again, both goats
were served as one single uh singular
offering that atoned for sin and removed
it from sight. There's no separating the
two. Lastly, as a bonus, I'd also like
to point out a type antitype analogy
that's much stronger than that of the
Adventist view. The type being the
Levitical Day of Atonement, which the
Adventists would agree with, and the
antitype being the day of Jesus's
crucifixion. In Matthew 27, Jesus the
Christ is presented alongside Jesus
Barabus. Bar meaning son of and aba
meaning the father. So we have two
Jesuses. Both are son of the father.
There are two identical goats. One is
sin laden and released just like the
scapegoat. The other is the innocent
lamb of God that is sacrificed as the
penalty for sin. The Lord's goat. Jesus
is both goats. Only Jesus is able to
meet the requirements of both goats as
well as all of the other sacrifices and
offerings that the law required. Jesus
is the burnt offering. Jesus is the sin
offering. Hebrews 13:10. Jesus is the
peace offering, the guilt offering.
Isaiah 53:10. He is the fragrant
offering. Ephesians 5:1. And so much
more. So there's no need to ascribe one
component of the law to Satan when Jesus
fulfills it all because Jesus fulfilled
all the law and the prophets. Matthew
5:17-20.
Jesus fulfills all the laws requirements
which include both the Lord's goat and
the scapegoat. From the sins being
placed on him, Isaiah 53:6, 1st Peter uh
2:24, to being taken outside the camp
bearing the sins, Hebrews 13:11-13,
Jesus meets every qualification of the
entirety of the sin and guilt offering.
So ask yourself why Keith is taking that
which only Jesus can fulfill and
accomplish and is ascribing it to Satan.
Ask yourself who might want to insert
themselves and take credit for that of
the Lord Jesus. Only Jesus can take away
sins. He alone is blemish free. He alone
atones for sins. He alone bore our
guilt. It is not possible for Satan to
be typified by the scapegoat. This is
blasphemous. It credits Satan with some
of the work that belongs exclusively to
the Lord Jesus. With that said, Marlin,
let's get into questions.
All right. Thank you both for that for
the opening statements. And so now we're
going to uh Keith, I think you're still
sharing your screen. Uh I'm not sure if
that's intentional,
but
Well, I'm curious. Is this thing capable
of like uh of doing a video uh showing a
video or No.
If if not, then I won't show.
That is a good question. No one's uh
presented a video via screen share.
So I'm I'm pretty ignorant of if it's
possible. Um if you have one, you could
try it, but I'll never
Yeah.
If you guys hear this, you know, just
let me know. Okay. If you can't hear it,
no big deal.
This is a video of um this is Dr. David
Moffett. He's a Presbyterian
uh reformed theologian from the
University of St. Andrews in uh
Scotland. This is um Brennan Breed, Dr.
Brennan Breed. He's an Old Testament
scholar, also Presbyterian. This right
here is another scholar. He is uh from
the um Presbyterian Church of Atlanta
and they are discussing the book of
Hebrews. Um and this is fairly recent, a
year ago. Um Hebrews 9:15-28.
Just
I'm not trying to be rude, but uh
yeah.
Isn't Isn't this supposed to be the
crossex?
Oh, sorry. What? Uh
what am I supposed to do? Am I allowed
to?
Yeah. The portion of this this debate is
30-minute crossex. But I think in our in
our discussions, I think it was uh said
that you wanted to present
uh something uh Keith.
Yeah. Yeah. I was going to going to
present kind of main arguments.
Okay. Um
I mean that's that's fine, but the just
I mean that's irre what they're saying
is actually irrelevant to you should
debate with me, not necessarily what
some other reformed guys are saying.
Well, I I just want to demonstrate that
uh this position is not simply an
Adventist position. The idea that there
is a heavenly sanctuary, literal
heavenly sanctuary is held by multiple
people.
I don't I don't deny that, Keith.
Different faith backgrounds.
I'm not denying that. But during the
during the crossex, we should engage
with what I said and what you said. So,
well, I understand there's other people
out there that have have whatever views.
But um
well, I'm I'm responding to one of the
things that you said, which is regarding
the heavenly sanctuary uh and whether or
not it's an actual literal place in the
book of Hebrews.
Right. But I that that wasn't the
argument I made, Keith. I I was trying
to steal man your position. I wanted the
audience to know what your guys'
position is. I didn't say that I
disagree that there is not a sanctuary
in heaven. That's not the point. The two
points that I said you need to address
because you're the affirmative. So the
argument I'm making that you have to
demonstrate as the affirmative you have
the burden of proof. So you need to
demonstrate that Jesus entered the most
holy place in heaven for the first time
in 1844 and that Satan meets the
qualifications of the scapegoat.
Leviticus 16:5 you you pointed to verse
9, but Leviticus 16:5 clearly says both
goats function as a singular sin
offering.
So,
um, I I would like to take the take some
of my 30 minutes to just present, not to
be arguing or cross-examining. I'll take
the last 15 minutes to ask you some
questions, but the first 15 minutes, I'm
just going to share stuff. So, you don't
have to worry about interjecting. I'll
just kind of share what I have and then
when I'm done, you can you can
interject. Uh, I'll cross-examine you if
if you will.
Um, so
all right. So anyway, this
Yeah. So go get let's do this. So let's
go ahead go ahead and present what you
what you're going to do and then
then we'll jump into the we'll jump into
the crossex after that. Does that make
sense?
Sure. That's that's
Yeah. Okay. All right. All right. You
got it.
So can you hear this?
Uh, no. We can't hear it.
Okay. So, I won't use this then. I'll
instead Can you see the paper that I
just put up?
All right. Let's see.
Yeah, we can see it probably. You could
probably blow it up a little bit more.
Think you got to add it 100%. Probably
expand. Yeah, that think that's good
right there.
All right. So, this is Dr. David
Moffett. He is the foremost uh or one of
the foremost theologians on the book of
Hebrews. And this is what he says. He
says the larger point of this study has
been to explore the possibility that
sacred space and sacrificial language in
Hebrews are not driven by metaphorical
theology that attempts to unpack the
spiritual heavenly or existential
significance of Christ's crucifixion.
The idea is that there is a tabernacle
temple in heaven. That this tabernacle
is the source for earthly structure.
That Jesus rose, ascended bodily, and
entered the heavenly tabernacle allow
for a theological model that has analogy
that's not metaphor. Indeed, the
relationship between the earthly and
heavenly tabernacles, the author assumes
described here in terms of homeomorphic
model, appears to ground an analogical
hermeneutic that allows him to explore
the biblical depictions of the earthly
sacred space and the priestly service
done there in order to better understand
what Jesus is doing in the heavenly
space and how his heavenly service
affects atonement. In Hebrews, Jesus's
death is one element of a larger ritual
process that culminates in his entry
into the heavenly tabernacle. There he
presents himself before God as an
offering that makes full atonement for
God's people. The epistle to the Hebrews
is not therefore structured around an
extended metaphor that focuses
exclusively on Jesus's death. Meaning
the whole concept that you laid out
about the day of atonement being
applicable to Christ's death and that
being what Hebrews is pointing towards
is exactly the opposite of what this
theologian is describing. Something that
is in any case hard to square with the
actual ritual process of sacrifice as
described in in Leviticus. Meaning, hey,
uh, if you read through the book of
Hebrews, you're going to notice that
there's so much flavor in it that to
reduce it down to the concept of just
being about Christ's death is a
reductionist reductionistic view of what
the author of Hebrews has in mind. And
it doesn't actually fit the cult that is
described in the book of Leviticus.
Rather the author the author takes
sacrificial practice in the earthly
sacred space of the tabernacle temper
temple to offer analogies for the way
things must be in the heavenly
tabernacle precisely because the earthly
space is a model of the heavenly space
and this is really important idea the
earthly is a model of the heavenly and
so the author of Hebrews actually goes
and says okay so now let's make
application s from what was happening in
the earthly to what happens in the
heavenly. In this way, the author
correlates the larger early Christian
story of Jesus with the biblical pattern
of sacrifice and shows by analogy how
Jesus's death, resurrection, and
ascension into God's presence and the
heavenly holy of holies affect ultimate
atonement. Um so to go to Hebrews
chapter um
nine uh there's a number of things that
need to be really clearly pointed out.
The first is if you read the New King
James Version or the NIV you're going to
experience a very different picture of
Hebrews chapter 9 and Hebrews chapter 10
than you will experience if you read it
say in the NESB. For example, you'll
notice in Hebrews 9:3 it talks about the
the second veil, the second apartment of
the tabernacle. it calls the most holy
place. Uh later on,
whoa. Later on, you'll see in Hebrews
9:8, it calls it the holiest of all. Um
and it uses that terminology, holiest of
all, most holy place, um over and over
again. But if you if you use the NASB
which is more clearly uh in line with
the the Greek which this this term here
hagio hagon haga hagion this is the holy
of holies it's the same word repeat
repeated twice the holy of holies okay
so if you go down a little bit later
you'll notice that they don't have in
Hebrews 9:8 the most holy place uh the
holy spirit is signifying this that the
way into The holies is actually the term
there. It's again this word hagya is the
term that's being used here. Um hagon.
There you go. The uh genative plural.
What is a plural? It means the holies.
So the holy spirit signifying this that
the way into the holies has not yet been
disclosed while the outer tabernacle is
still standing. And it uses over and
over again this concept of the holies um
instead of the most holy place as you
saw before. For Christ did not enter a
holy place made with hands a mere copy
of the true one but into heaven itself
now to appear in the presence of God for
us. The whole point of this, what I'm
saying here is that this is not actually
language that is speaking about the most
holy place and the death of Christ. This
is language that is speaking about the
inauguration of the most holy place, the
holy place, the entire tabernacle, the
covenant service. That's what's being
described here. And that's why it uses
this language first here uh inaugurated
with blood. Therefore, even the first
covenant was not inaugurated without
blood because he's talking about the
inauguration of the tabernacle, not the
day of atonement. Um, now notice here as
we as we go back a little bit here. Um,
it starts talking about the tabernacle
services. Um, the inner tabernacle
service, the outer tabernacle service.
And then it says this. It says, "But
into the second, the high priest enters
once a year, not without blood, which he
offers for himself. the Holy Spirit thus
signifying that the way into the holies
has not yet been disclosed while the
outer tabernacle is still standing. Now
there's two ways to view this. It's very
important to understand what these two
ways are. The first way to view this is
to say well Christ went from the holy
place uh service to the second apartment
service the most holy place service.
The other way to view this is to say
that Christ went from nowhere. He he was
a sacrifice on earth into the heavenly
tabernacle and the tabernacle on earth
was ineffective.
That's the of the author here. It's
whether the tabernacle was ineffective
or whether the firstart
tabernacle was represented here in these
verses uh as being ineffective. Um so
for example this is this says for there
was a tabernacle prepared the outer one
in which were the lampstand the table
the sacred bread that is called the holy
place but beyond behind the second veil
there's a tabernacle which is called the
holy of holies um having a golden altar
of incense in the ark of the covenant
covered on all sides with gold in which
a golden jar holding the mana and
Aaron's rod which uh budded in the
tables of of the covenant and above it
were the cherubim of glory overshadowing
the mercy seat. But of these things we
cannot now speak. He's he's describing
the entire tabernacle. When these things
having been have been so prepared that
the priests are continually entering the
outer tabernacle performing the divine
service, that's the outer compartment of
the tabernacle.
But second, only the high priest enters
once a year, not without blood, which he
offers for himself and for the sins of
the people committed in ignorance. the
Holy Spirit signifying this that the way
into either the most holy place or the
way into the tabernacle period has not
yet been disclosed while the outer
tabernacle is still standing. I hope I'm
making sense. The argument between ver
um us as Adventists and other Christians
is that um and Miles specifically
earlier was that Christ needed to have
entered the most holy place in 1844,
which is directly contrary to what it
says in Hebrews chapter 9. That's his
argument. What I'm suggesting is that it
doesn't say that he entered the most
holy place in Hebrews chapter 9. What it
says is that he entered into the holies
or or the tabernacle itself uh instead
of saying that he entered into the most
holy place. The rest of the language
here is inauguration language declaring
that very thing that Christ inaugurated
the tabernacle um in the heavenly places
and began began the ministry in heaven,
the heavenly ministry. first the first
apartment ministry and second the day of
atonement ministry is what he did next.
So that's that's just speaking to some
of that uh atonement language. I I also
want to mention a couple other things
here. I'm going to stop sharing for a
moment, let you look at my face. I want
to mention that um he mentioned Hebrews
chapter 13.
And Hebrews chapter 13
is a very important um
text that talks about
um the outer altar. Hebrews 13.
Oh, let's see where is it. Hebrews
13:12.
I'll go ahead and reshare now my screen.
Um,
there we go. Got it pulled up on my
paper here. Let's
Hebrews 13:12 says that Jesus suffered
outside the camp just like the
scapegoat. If this is a reference to a
sanctuary upon an altar outside the camp
found in Leviticus 16, it is going to be
a reference to verse 27. Not the
scapegoat. He's not a sacrifice upon an
altar, even outside the camp. Notice
what it says in Hebrews 13 11 and 12.
For the bodies of those animals whose
blood is brought into the holy place by
the high priest as an offering for sin
are burned outside the camp. Therefore,
Jesus also that he might sanctify the
people through his own blood suffered
outside the gate. Now, this is often
what Christians use to point to. See,
the obvious reference to the scapegoat
is listed here in Hebrews chapter 13.
But if you look at Leviticus 16 27,
notice the language, but the bull of the
sin offering and the goat of the sin
offering, which is not the goat for
Aazel. It's the goat for the Lord whose
blood was brought in to make atonement
in the holy place shall be taken outside
the camp and they shall burn their
hides, their flesh and their refuge in
the fire. When it's making note of this
whole concept of a goat or a sacrifice
happening outside of the camp and
representing something, this is the
reference. It's referencing the goat of
the Lord being burned outside of the
camp, not the scapegoat. In fact, it has
no reference to the scapegoat
whatsoever. Other thing it could be a
reference to is the Old Testament
passages Leviticus 4:121
that speak about uh regular um the the
continual or daily offerings or the
first apartment offerings and sacrifices
being burned both inside the camp on the
altar of burnt offering as well as
outside of the camp as well. Isaiah 53.
I want to speak to Isaiah 53. If you
read Isaiah 53, there's actually no
language that is unique to the goat for
Aazelle. None whatsoever. Read Isaiah
chapter 53. Um, in fact, I would suggest
this that the language in Isaiah chapter
53, there's actually a couple pieces or
notes within Isaiah 53 that is unique to
the first apartment service. So Isaiah
53:7 says, "He was led as a lamb to the
slaughter." There's no lamb in the day
of atonement sacrifices. There is
there's five sacrifices actually.
There's there's uh the goat and a ram
that that was uh sacrificed along with
the goat. There's a bull and a ram that
was sacrificed along with the bull. And
then there's the goat for aazel which
was carried out and set free in the
wilderness. and often the ritual became
them kicking it down over the tallest
mountain or the strong rugged mountain.
But you notice here that uh there's a
reference to a lamb. Well, that has
nothing to do with the day of atonement
service. That has to do with the daily
service. Um the burnt offerings that
were offered daily or other sacrifices
that are daily or first apartment
sacrifices. There's another reference
too. It says, "When you make his soul an
offering for sin, offering for sin."
speaking to the goat of the Lord that
was meant to be an offering for sin or
all of the other offerings that could
have been offered for sin. Specifically
speaking in Leviticus chapter 4, it
describes a sin offering which would be
associated on the day of atonement with
the goat for the Lord or the ram which
was sacrificed with the goat for the
Lord or or one of the regular uh uh sin
offerings that you could you could make
in the regular um first apartment
services. All right. So then now uh to
speak to some of what he was mentioning
about I have the burden to make Satan
fit um the scapegoat. I just want to
speak a little bit to um traditional
Jewish views on this um because this is
this is a later development uh of the
Christian church um which I'm not always
opposed to uh us coming up with
different fulfillments but this is this
is preceding the Christian view of of uh
of Aazelle or the scapegoat. This was
not they um what they viewed.
Yeah.
Hey Keith, I'm have to cut you off
there. You you you spent that 15 minutes
of your your first crossex to um to
present and now I think it's time to go
ahead and uh go just go ahead and engage
with M with Miles now for the rest of
that 15 minutes.
Keith, nothing you just said addressed
my points. You weren't listening. I did
not say that there is not a heavenly
sanctuary. I was steelmanning your
position. I wanted the viewer to
understand what you guys are saying. You
didn't address either of the points that
I made. However, you actually walked
into a trap in your own presentation.
You said that Hebrews 9:8 is not talking
about the the most holy place because if
you use other translation, it says the
holy places. Keith, that includes both.
Are you forgetting 1844? That's the key.
You guys claim he didn't enter into the
most holy place until 1844. If that is
falsified and Jesus isn't doing what you
guys claim right now, pointing to other
reformed theologians that believe
there's an actual tabernacle in heaven
does not mean that they affirm the
investigative judgment. You're ignoring
that part. Second off, you're pointing
to Jewish sources, Jews who reject
Jesus, mind you, and not pointing to
scripture. You haven't dealt with the
fact that Leviticus 16:5
says the scapegoat and the Lord's goat
function as a singular sin offering. So
in your type, both the scapegoat and the
Lord's goat function as a sin offering.
We didn't say a sacrifice. I never said
sacrifice. Go back and listen to my
opening. I never said the scapegoat was
a sacrifice. I said that the scapegoat
and the Lord's goat function as a
singular sin offering. But then in the
antitype, you guys want to say the
Lord's goat is Jesus because he was
sacrificed. But the Lord but the
scapegoat is Satan because the sa the
scapegoat wasn't sacrificed. And like
Satan's going to be cast in the lake of
fire because he's responsible. Uh he
typifies the scapegoat. Keith, the law
requires both a scapegoat and the Lord's
goat. So now that we're in the crossex
and you got done saying a bunch of
things that don't actually address what
I'm saying, we're going to ask questions
now. You said earlier in your opening,
I'm going to quote you because I want to
quote it correctly. You said, "We
believe that Jesus suffered the guilt
and shame we deserve." So my question to
you then, because this it is said that
the scapegoat bears the guilt of the
people. So do you agree or yes or no, do
you believe that Satan bears the guilt
for sin?
No, I don't believe. Well, he bears his
own culpability for it. He doesn't bear
our culpability for it.
No. No. No. Right. Right. So who is the
guilt offering?
The the guilt offering what there's
require multiple correct and one of them
is a guilt offering.
Okay. So you're specifically mentioning
a guilt offering
because the law requires a guilt
offering and the scapegoat bore the
guilt of the people. So in your type,
the scapegoat bears the guilt. And
Leviticus 16:10 says that atonement is
made on the scapegoat. So is atonement
made on the scapegoat in the antitype as
well or not? And if not, why does that
not port over?
So um I think that's a really great
question. Um first of all, can I address
the point about the heavenly sanctuary
and whether no
answer to the most holy place?
No. No, it's my turn. Which one do you
want? This is the This is This is the
question I'm asking right now. You just
had 15 minutes of monologue. I want to
know, do you believe that the that in
the So, in your guys's type, both goats,
you're agreeing that both goats function
as a sin offering. And Leviticus 16:10
says the scapegoat had atonement made on
it. So, in your antitype where Satan is
the scapegoat, does the scapegoat have
atonement made on it? Because you guys
don't believe the atonement is finished
yet. Correct.
Correct. We believe that atonement is a
process.
Okay. You're right. So, and when does it
end? Is it after the scapegoat or is it
before the scapegoat?
It is after the scapegoat.
Okay. So, you believe that the scapegoat
is a part of the atonement. So, you
believe that Jesus,
right? So, you believe that Jesus and
Satan both uh partake in the atonement.
This is blasphemous heresy and you need
to repent of this. That's why that's why
people are skeptical of Adventists, man.
That's blasphemy. Do you not understand
that? You're saying Satan is a part of
the atonement, man. That is insane.
Don't point to reformed theologians and
try and act like, "Oh, there's other
Christians that are No, bro. No, no, no,
no, no. Give this up, man. Give this up.
Think about what you just said."
That is insane. You're taking something
that is required by the law and saying
it's ultimately in the antitype
fulfilled in Satan. You're making Satan
the tragic hero.
So, uh, in Revelation 20:es 1-3,
it very clearly indicates that Satan is
the scapegoat as you see those
typologies play out throughout the book
of Revelation. I can demonstrate that to
you if you give me like five minutes.
Well, you also said that Revelation 1 is
a is a picture of Jesus doing the exact
work of the Levitical ironic priest.
Yet, if you read to the end of chapter
1, it says the lampstands that Jesus is
walking amongst is the churches. So, why
are you taking the cryptic?
You said that. I said he he was saying
exactly I I didn't say he was doing
exactly what the ironic priest was
doing.
You're putting words. You guys teach
You guys teach that until 1844 Jesus was
doing the daily ministration in the holy
place. Correct. Yes or no?
Uh, correct.
Right. Right. You guys believe and you
depict in all of your second commandment
violations Jesus wearing the Levitical
ironic priesthood garb. Correct.
The linen uh
the ephod.
Correct.
Yeah.
Right. So you guys don't act like I'm
painting this as something that you guys
don't teach. You believe that that was
the type and the antitype is fulfilled
in Christ. And he's essentially doing
the work of the Levitical ironic
priesthood. He was in the outer
apartment doing the daily ministry until
1844 when he then entered the most holy
place for the first time then. But you
pointed to Revelation 1.
No. See that's where I disagree with
you. So I I don't actually believe that
Christ entered into the most holy place
in 1844. I think that you know in my
view and I think that Adventists are
split on this. Half of them believe that
Christ entered a different room or an
actual place in the heavenly tabernacle
in 1844. The other half believe that he
started the most holy day service in
1844. And I fall in in that line of
thinking. There's a movable throne and
that's how the first group sees him
going from the holy place to the most
holy place.
So then the so then the earthly the
heavenly is not an uh the earthly was
not an exact copy of the heavenly thing
then Keith because the Lord's presence
God God's presence was contained in the
holy place. If you're saying that oh he
moves around his throne has wheels like
it says in Ezekiel like Anthony tried to
say on the last of it.
I'm saying that's what's
okay. What I'm saying is the holy place
doesn't have a veil between the most
holy and the holy place there. It's it's
a functioning room
where God is. But that doesn't mean that
that Christ, even though he's in the
same room, can't have one ministry and
then start performing a different
ministry at a different time period.
The book of Hebrews that you were just
in, if you read the whole book says that
Jesus entered into the presence of God,
unlike the Levitical ironic priest that
used the animals, the the blood of
animals, Jesus by the means of his own
blood one time entered into the presence
of God, sat down at the right hand, and
sits mediating on behalf of his people
until all of his enemies are to be made
a foottool. Where are you getting the
idea that he wasn't in there until some
later point that this happened later on
and that what he's doing currently is
work.
He sat down at the throne of God on the
very throne of God. I mean, Revelation
says, okay, that he's coming out from
the throne of God. Like, I've got no
problem saying that he went into the
most holy place, but uh he was doing the
work of the first service for for those
1844 years.
You also missed the point of what I was
bringing up in Hebrews 9. you went to
Hebrews 9 to and a you actually shot
yourself in the foot because you said it
actually doesn't say the most holy
place. If you go to other translations,
it says the holiest places. Okay. Well,
again, that refutes 1844 and I
understand you may not be defending
that, but that is the traditional
position of your church.
Um the point being is that you said or
or it says that the work that the work
of the uh the first apartment and the
stuff that was going on there, you guys
were claiming that he was still doing
that work until a later period. So
unless the book of Hebrews was written
after this period that you're saying,
are you saying that at Jesus's
ascension, he went directly into the
holy most holy place and that there's no
veil separating the two?
Yes. Exactly.
Okay. So Okay. So there's no different
then it's not a copy of the earthly.
Don't say you said in your opening that
the heaven is a copy of the earthly Paul
says in Hebrews chapter chapter 8.
Okay. So the earthly didn't have a veil
between the holy and the most holy
place. Come on Keith earthly. So the
earthly had a veil. Do you know what the
purpose of the veil was?
Yeah.
Do you know what the purpose
of the veil?
All Well, it depends what you're talking
about because all of the stuff in the
temple pointed to Christ. He's the light
of the world. He's the bread of life.
He's the uh the curtain is actually his
flesh. We're told in Hebrews that
typified Christ. Uh he's the door that
you enter into through the
say that the curtain is just flesh.
That's that's not what it says. Do you
do you What's the purpose of the veil?
What's the purpose of the veil in in I
know you're pointing to Hebrews chapter
10 19 to 20, but what's the purpose of
the veil in the Old Testament?
No, no, no. We're not we're getting
sidetracked now. We're get we're getting
sidetracked now. We're not doing this.
We're getting sidetracked now.
We're going back. You already admitted
you said that when I asked is Satan part
of the atonement? You said yes.
Now, I want to know back to that first
question I asked. Do you believe that
that Satan bears the guilt of sin? Not
just the guilt, his own guilt, his own
cul culpability, but do you actually
believe that Satan bears the guilt for
sin
for sin in its entire answer previous
like do you know what the purpose of the
No, it's my cross. No, you can ask me
that in your time. It's my crossex for
15 minutes.
Yes. Yes. Yeah. Cuz I can Yes. Yes. Cuz
I control my You can ask that. You can
ask that. No, I I just said you can ask
that question and it's your time to ask
questions. It's my question time. Do you
believe that Satan bears the guilt for
sin?
Not just the culpability, but actually
bears the guilt for sin.
Yes, he bears his responsibility.
Okay.
No. No. That's not what I'm asking.
Yeah. And you're saying that his
responsibility
doesn't bear my responsibility,
right? But you're saying that the
ultimate responsibility of sin is
Satan's responsibility. You're saying
that Satan's the originator, right?
Satan's the originator, right? Okay. So
you believe that Satan is the guilt
offering. So you believe that Satan's
the guilt offering and you believe that
he's a part of the atonement. Was
atonement completed at the cross?
No.
Okay. So you're saying only the atoning
sacrifice was complete at the cross?
Right.
Uh correct.
Just the atoning sacrifice. Okay. Then
then you must concede then again you
must concede that Satan's part of the
atonement because as shown Leviticus
16:5 says both goats function as a
singular sin offering. Keith, abandon.
I don't think that it says that. I don't
think that it says that. If you go back
to Leviticus chapter 16, let's read it.
Read. Yeah, here it is. And he shall
take talking about Aaron from the
congregation of the people of Israel two
male goats for a sin offering and one
ram and one verse Leviticus 16:5.
And he shall take from the congregation
of the people of Israel. And before we
don't do the gish gallop, don't jump all
over. Don't do the Bible. the hopscotch
exed Jesus the Bible ping pong. And he
shall take from the congregation of the
people of Israel two male goats for a
sin offering.
And then in verse 10, but the goat
fellowship
you want me. Okay, I'll continue. Well,
okay.
And and one so you want me
Okay, that doesn't change that doesn't
change the point.
And then my my for the sake of saving
time. No, it doesn't because it says the
two goats are for a singular sin
offering. No, it doesn't because the ram
had nothing to do with that. And Jesus
is the burnt offering. So, he's the the
two he fulfills both goats, the
scapegoat and the Lord's goat and the
burnt offering. No, it doesn't change
anything. And then in verse 10, it says
that atonement is made over the
scapegoat. You're saying that Satan and
Jesus both accomplish the atonement.
This is blasphemous heresy. You need to
repent of this. Um, this is insane. And
I'm glad that this is now on record.
This is why I like having these
discussions so Christians can see this
is what Seventh Day Adventists believe.
So you'll notice that if you look at
Leviticus chapter 16 and you read it to
the end, the ram actually gets connected
with the sin offering uh for the goat
for the Lord. Um and they get offered
together down at the end of the chapter
that both of them get sacrificed. the
altar.
Can I ask you?
Well, no, because you're rambling again
and you're not addressing this. I am
affirming that Jesus I'm affirming
I'm affirming that Jesus fulfills all of
this. The problem is for you because
you're ignoring the clear fact that it
says two male goats for a sin offering.
You guys want to jump to verse 9 and
say, "See, it's only the one that was
sacrificed that's a sin offering." It
doesn't say that to the exclusion of the
scapegoat. The two goats are presented
for a singular sin offering. Thank you.
This is what I wanted to get out of the
cross- examination. I wanted this on
record.
So, just so it's clear, I'm not saying
that he's not an offering for sin, but
it's a it's a different offering than
what you're saying.
Keith, the scapegoat is necessary to to
fulfill all of the law. You're saying
that by saying that Christ does not
fulfill this, you're saying that Satan
actually ultimately fulfills a portion
of the law. How do you not see this,
man? Take the blinders off. God, I pray
that he takes the blinders off of your
eyes. Do you not understand and hear
what you're saying, man? I know I'm
getting a little wor, but seriously,
this is insane, dude. You don't
understand what you're actually saying
right now, and you're just refusing to
see what's clearly there in front of
you. Abandon this, man. Lead this
movement. Come to the true and living
God. Come worship with us. We're not
gonna laugh at you. We're not
interrupting and be able to hear like
Well, it's my time and you took 15
minutes, Keith, while you monologued.
Well, you took 15 minutes to monologue,
which we
for 15 minutes, but you asked me
questions and then you wouldn't let me
answer them. Do you want me to answer
the questions?
I'm going to answer the question.
I don't want you to I don't want you to
gish gallop. I want you to address it. I
don't want you to say I want you to
think about something. Miles, Miles,
stop talking for a minute. I want you to
think about something. Do you No, no,
no. Hold on, Marlin. Do you want to hear
the argument or do you just want to talk
over top? Because there's a difference
between somebody searching for the truth
and trying to understand somebody's
position versus just talking over
somebody every time they start to answer
your questions. You can't actually
understand their position if you just
talk over top of them. and you make a
hump noise and you roll your eyes and
then you say things like, "Oh, you need
to abandon your position." I'm telling
you why I believe this,
but you you won't even let me tell you
why I believe it.
Do you want to hear?
We we we agreed to 15minute openings and
30 minute cross exams and then you did a
15-minute monologue. I didn't say a
word. I then ask precise questions and
you say when I interrupt you, which we
agreed, when it's our time, you control
the time. I knew you would do this. You
want to jump later on and say, "Well, a
ram down here, Keith." That doesn't
address verse five. That's the elephant
in the room. I I want to hear your
answer to the question I'm asking. Now,
you're talking over me. Now you're
talking over me, Keith.
I don't want you to answer other
Okay, Miles. Let's let's allow let's
allow Keith to answer it. Let let him
answer your question. Go ahead, Keith.
Okay, listen. It is very clear and and
you ask why am I jumping to Jews to talk
about the Old Testament tabernacle and
its fulfillment and blah blah blah. Why
would I jump to the Jews? They don't
even believe in Jesus.
The reason that scholars go back to
Jewish thought is to understand what the
Jewish ideas were about the fulfillment
of these things that they were
practicing on a regular basis. So the
idea that the Jews thought that these
were that this was fulfilled in certain
ways and this was done in certain ways
is actually instructive to us as
Christians to know hey this is how they
applied it. Now, how can we take that
and apply that to a new testament
reality with Jesus? So, you have to
understand it how it was originally
understood in order to make those New
Testament applications.
So, for example,
the Jews never believed that aazelle
was a substitute sacrifice. They
believed that
I never said that sin
for the purggation of sin and that he
did a work of atonement. Those things
are very clear. He did the did a work of
atonement but he did it by purging the
camp of sin getting evil out of the
camp. Right? It's different than what
the goat of the Lord did when he died on
behalf of the people and was offered as
a sacrifice substitute
uh for sin on behalf of the people.
Meaning he suffered their guilt, their
shame and their um their death. That's
what the guilt of the Lord did as
opposed to the goat for Aazelle.
Um and I can read some quotes here, but
I won't. I I never said that both.
Respond. Go ahead and respond to Keith.
Keith, you keep you're attacking a straw
man. Not once. Go back and listen to my
opening. Listen to what I've said thus
far. I have not one time said that the
scapegoat was a sacrifice. Stop
attacking a straw man. Pointing to
Jewish sources to develop New Testament
Christian doctrine is not a the path
that you should travel. You're not
dealing with scripture. Of course, you
can appeal to history and tradition and
and certain things like that to glean
and learn things, but deal with the
text. You still in that whole thing did
not deal with verse 5 because you can't
deal with verse 5. That's fine. Let's
move on to the uh verse the next the
next section.
Let me be clear. You have you have two
goats and you have a burnt offering
which is a ram. All right? Uh you follow
the so and then the goats are called the
sin offering, right?
One is a sin offering
as a sacrifice,
substitutional sacrifice on behalf of
the people. The other is a sin offering
of purggation that takes the evil out of
the camp. This is the whole concept of
the sin being removed and being purged
outside of the camp. So he carries the
sin outside of the camp. This is what
revelation what I said in my case.
All right. So, Miles, go ahead and go
ahead. So, Miles, go ahead and respond
to what Keith just said.
That's exactly what I'm saying, Keith.
Behold the lamb of God that takes away
the sin of the world. Jesus is
not the goat of God, is it?
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on, Keith. Let
him finish. Go ahead, Miles. Go ahead.
Uh oh, Keith. Was the uh the the Lord's
goat. Was that a lamb? Don't pull that.
Come on, dude. Obviously, everything is
not a one to one. And a ram and a goat.
If we want to go back through Leviticus
and Deuteronomy and look at the
requirements for the laws, sacrifices,
and offerings, rams, goats, uh, and
lambs could sometimes be interchangeably
used. It had to be blemish free.
Something else you didn't at all
mention. You haven't dealt with the fact
that I that I pointed out all animals
that were involved, not just in the
Levitical Day of Atonement, but period
had to be blemish free. Satan doesn't
meet the qualifications. You haven't
demonstrated any of that. You're
appealing to apocalyptic books like
Revelation where you can try and work in
some cryptic meaning where it doesn't
say anything that you're saying. Simply
being cast into the lake of Stop
interrupting.
Satan being cast into the lake of fire
has nothing to do with the wilderness
and being taken out into the wilderness
and thrown off and Jesus being typified
by the individual who takes him out
there. No, you stated it yourself. The
scapegoat bore the sins and took them
away from the people. You're saying
Satan did that. That's why I said you
needed to repent. I'm sorry if that
offends you, but I'm not going to have
the blood on my hands. I just wanted
this on record for people to hear. Um, I
think that they can deduce for
themselves. I'm sorry that I've talked
over you some. I got a little bit worked
up there. I apologize, but man, we
agreed to 15-minute openings, 30-minute
crossex, and then you gave a 15-minute
monologue. I didn't interrupt. And then
when I ask questions, you want to do
some of the gish gallop and then try and
like steer the time. And I just I don't
appreciate that. So, I'm sorry, but um
let's move on to the
I did say in Facebook before we even had
this debate that I wanted to do the
introduction and then I was going to
monologue more. You asked me
specifically after uh you did your
introduction and you were totally fine
with that. You said you can use your 30
minutes however you wanted and I got 15
minutes. So,
but then we agreed but then we agreed to
agreed how I wanted. Keith, do do we
really have to post the receipts?
Yeah, we don't we don't have to do that.
But [laughter] hey, if there was any if
there's any area of miscommunication, I
take the blame for that. I should make
sure that everyone's on the same page.
Let's get on to the next Let's get on to
the next portion.
You got You guys are good. So, what
we're going to do now, we're going to go
to the Q&A. We got some questions here.
And if anyone out there uh get a last qu
last minute question in um and we'll
tackle your questions. So our first
question here and you'll see it pop up
at the bottom of the screen there
is Mr. Reverend
a avid supporter of the gospel truth uh
he making me laugh some of the comments
he make but anyway uh Levit 16 says the
scapegoat makes atonement by being
presented alive to God with the
confessed sins of Israel. How in the
world can Satan make atonement by giving
uh by being presented alive to God like
Jesus?
What you say, Keith?
So, the presentation
um was for the purpose of God deciding
which goat would be the goat of the Lord
and the goat for Aazelle. After it was
decided which goat would be the goat for
the Lord and the goat for Aazelle, the
goat for Aazelle, they did put their
hands upon their head of the goat and
they did proclaim the sins of Israel
upon that goat and to clarify
purification ritual. Um he then purified
the camp by they sent him out of the
camp uh with all the evils or all the
culpability for evil. I would point to a
couple texts um in the Old Testament
like uh Deuteronomy chapter 19 that uh
speaks about this kind this idea that uh
of um of culpability. Uh let me just uh
real quick here
um pull up my text. Says this um an
accuser receives the penalty for his
false accusations.
uh Deuteronomy chapter 19 18 and 19. The
judges shall make careful inquiry. And
indeed, if the witness is a false
witness who has testified falsely
against his brother, then you shall do
to him as he thought to have done to his
brother. So you shall put away the evil
from among you. Roy Gain makes a good
point in his book Alter Call regarding
this text. When Satan accuses forgiven
people of being unforgiven, he
identifies himself not only as a liar,
but also as a malicious false witness.
Deuteronomy states that the serious
consequences that an Israelite would
bring upon himself if he tried to
destroy someone through the judicial
process by means of false testimony. Um,
another example of laying on the hands
and them having culpability is in
Leviticus 24, uh, where it says, "Bring
out of the camp the one who cursed, and
let all who heard him lay their hands on
his head, and let all the congregation
stone him and speak to the people of
Israel, saying, Whoever curses his name
shall bear his sin. Whoever blasphemes
the name of the Lord shall surely be put
to get put to death. All the
congregation shall stone him." There's
evidence in scripture of the camp
putting culpability upon uh somebody for
their own guilt in sin and then removing
that evil from the camp.
All right, Miles, what are your
thoughts?
I just got to say everything he just
said, notice how Christians view all of
that as being Jesus. Jesus is the one
that purges sin. Jesus is the one that
makes atonement. Jesus is the one that
takes the sins away from the people. Uh
he didn't address at all the question
and he didn't address the problem of
Satan not being able to meet the
qualifications that the law requires for
all the animal sacrifices which is why
his type antitype analogy breaks down.
All right. All right. Here's a question
for you, Miles.
Miles, how would you explain Numbers
25:7-8
King James version, New King James
Version, where the eradication of the
wicked is said to make atonement for
Israel. This atonement wasn't
substitutionary as they were evil.
I don't know about that passage. I'd
need to look at it and look at the
preceding context. Uh but it's not
talking about the Levitical Day of
Atonement. So, the context is more than
likely different there, but I would need
to look at that. I'm not familiar with
it.
All right. Uh Keith, any thoughts?
Um, I'd have to look at the the text as
well.
All right,
we can look at it. I don't mind looking
at it right now.
Yeah, it probably took a little bit of
time to get the full context of that, so
we won't spend too much time there. But,
uh, [laughter] but all right. Uh, we'll
move on. Sorry, East King. Uh, next time
perhaps uh maybe lay your question a
little more fluid there and uh be able
to answer that question a little better
there. All right, this for you Keith.
Could you please address Miles's
argument that the scapegoat had to be
had to be blemish free and how Satan
actually can accomplish that?
So that's a great question. Um
I don't know that the idea that the
scapegoat had to be uh blemishfree
is um significant
uh to the point that um well let me try
to say it like this.
Both goats had to be blemish free
because God was the one choosing them.
All right, if that makes sense. So if
you brought a goat that was not blemish
free and you brought a goat that was
blemish free, you would essentially be
making the choice as to which goat is
the goat of the Lord and which goat is
the goat for Aazelle. If you bring two
identical goats, right? Then God chooses
which goat is the goat for the Lord and
which goat is the goat represents the
goat for Aazelle. I don't know if that
makes sense.
All right, Miles. Any thoughts,
folks? Read Deuteronomy 17:1, Leviticus
4:23,22
through uh somewhere in chapter 22. It's
all throughout the law. All the animals
that are used for offerings and
sacrifices had to be blemish free.
There's no way around this uh without
saying essentially that Satan is somehow
blemish free. It's also in the name,
folks. Scapegoat. A scapegoat is one who
is blamed, who's not at fault. That's
the opposite of Satan.
All right.
That that again I I noted that that was
like not time for responses. Not time
for responses.
Hold on. Yeah. Q&A.
Miles, you're being so petty, bro. Like
I noted that that is a contemporary
application to a historical term. It's
inaccurate.
Keith.
Keith. Yeah. Do a Q&A. No response, man.
I'm sorry, man. No response. All right.
So, we have a question here uh for
Keith. Isaiah 53:410. identify Christ as
bearing our sin uh sorrows and offering
for sin etc. How is Satan involved in
any of this?
So again um you know we believe that
Christ fulfilled all the sacrifices um
and so he most definitely is the lamb of
God. In fact, the most common
terminology used to describe Christ is
lamb. Um, speaking to uh sacrifices that
were used all throughout the tabernacle
services, uh, the first apartment
services. Um, however, the the day of
atonement sacrifice wasn't a lamb. Um,
there weren't any lambs. There was two
goats, a ram, two rams, and a bull. And
um so the concept of Isaiah 53 speaking
about the lamb of God, no problem. It it
completely represents Christ. We believe
that uh uh the work of atonement by
Christ is is fulfilled or typified in uh
both services. But specifically, you
know,
Isaiah 53 speaks about Christ being the
lamb of God takes away the sins of the
world.
Right. Uh any thoughts, Miles?
But it wasn't the Lord's goat. Keith,
you br you brought that up earlier. You
said the Lord's not a lamb. Um or the
the the goat. It's not a a goat. Uh
Jesus is the lamb. Well, he's the Lord's
goat is not a lamb either. But notice,
folks, he said all the offerings or uh
he said all of the uh sacrifices that
Jesus fulfills all the sacrifices, but
notice he didn't say Jesus fulfills all
of the offerings which also were a
requirement of the law. And shout out to
Colin CMBB, the ambassador. What's up,
bro?
All right. And here's another question
here.
Uh, Leviticus 16 scapegoat was led out
by the camp by a fit man. Jesus Christ
was led out to place to the place of
crucifixion by a fit man. Simon of
Serene. How can Satan be the scapegoat
who led Satan out?
Well, again, um, I think it's super
clear. Read the book of First Enoch,
chapter 10. Uh you can read Revelation
chapter 20. It's it's they're almost
like identical. Um speaking to Leviticus
chapter 16, uh ascribe all sin to
Aazelle. Uh the strong man that takes uh
Satan out of the camp. Um, it's, you
know, it's the person that leads this
and scapegoat is really I'm just using
that term because you guys are using it,
but and it's a common term, but that's
that's the idea is that Satan will be
removed. Evil will be purged from the
camp. Um, and if you follow that's my
that's my main argument. If you learn
nothing else from today, just review
this concept of how Revelation walks you
through first of all the first apartment
and then the second apartment and the
feast of the Lord, right? It talks
about, you know, you have uh the feast
of of trumpets and then you have the day
of atonement and then you have the feast
of tabernacles. that the day of
atonement falls both within the feast of
the Lord and it falls within the
tabernacle services in the book of
Revelation. And in both of those
applications, the day of atonement um in
Revelation chapter 20, Satan is
identified as the goat that is taken out
of the camp as sin is purged from within
the camp. It's extremely obvious.
All right, Miles, any thoughts?
No, I would just say notice folks, he
appealed to the book of Enoch. Um, go
back and watch this debate and see who
was referencing scripture. Go look at
the scripture in context and see uh see
who was
Okay, Keith.
All right, guys.
Go uh
go ahead. Go ahead, Marlin.
All right. [clears throat] Yeah, that
concludes the debate and the Q&A. Um,
this is probably one of my shorter ones.
I usually go for like two hours, two and
a half hours, but nonetheless, I know
it's a little choppiness as far as the
format is concerned and things like
that. A little maybe some confusion
there and not take full blame for that.
So, I'm sorry guys. Hopefully that
doesn't uh stain the credit uh per se of
you guys interacting on this platform.
But nonetheless, I do appreciate you
guys and I appreciate you guys uh uh
ability to converse even though this is
a hot topic. Obviously, there's a lot of
emotion involved here. Miles, you being
a part of 7day Adventist at some point
in time in your life and your father's
still in it. Keith, you're under his
father uh in the 7th Day Adventist. So,
I understand the emotion that's entailed
here and obviously Miles feels that you
should come to Christ and repent of
that. But nonetheless, we see the
emotion there and that's understandable.
And uh but I do appreciate you guys so
much and I hope that um you guys will
just to do this again sometime
uh I'm a Christian. I know Christ and
you know my ears
and I cannot hear my earbuds just went
out on me.
Uh stand by one second so I can actually
hear what you guys are saying. Hold on.
[snorts]
I can hear you now. Had to break out the
old backup headphones that I haven't
used in like years. So, [gasps]
yeah. But what were you saying, Keith?
Sorry about that.
I was just saying I'm a Christian. Um,
you know, and
I feel like, you know, kind of, you
know, not being able to dialogue about
uh theological topics and come to an
understanding of them without calling
someone to repentance because they
disagree with you is making things
personal.
Keith, you disagree on who bears the sin
and guilt and if Jesus alone
accomplishes the atonement. This isn't
about instruments in church, my man.
This isn't like a tertiary uh should you
know should we have instruments in
church or should we have uh you know the
regulative principle of worship which
those things are important but bro you
said that Satan is a part of the
atonement I I don't know how to say any
other way that's not Christian my man
and you can't depart from that and say
that Jesus alone does not accomplish the
atonement whether you want to say it's a
process or not you are ascribing things
of the law to being accomplished by not
Jesus is alone but Jesus and Satan. That
is the logical conclusion.
So what I'm suggesting is that if
scripture says this, then we should be
able to tease it out and figure it out
rather than calling me not a Christian
just because you disagree with me.
That's not why I'm saying that,
Keith. I did not say because you
disagree with me, you're not a
Christian. No, it's not, Keith. You are
saying the the it's it's almost insane
that I have to explain this.
Look, Keith, this would be like somebody
saying real quick, real quick, real
quick, real quick, real quick.
It would be like somebody Keith said
that
I'm not going to Let's just move on.
Okay. Okay. All right, guys. So, all
right.
This stuff will get hashed out. This
stuff will get taken care of. And I you
know what I would like to I would like
to see if one of you guys were open up a
conversation as far as invite each other
on you guys' channel so you guys can
sort of deal with this and uh deal with
the conversation of this topic.
More than happy to do it
in a in a more I guess like this is more
formatted and perhaps a more open
dialogue would help. But nonetheless,
you know, I think you guys should
continue this conversation and I think
it' be helpful. Uh, as I mentioned to
you earlier, Keith, you know, we don't
get a lot of 7day Adventists doing this
type of stuff, you know. So, I
definitely I definitely appreciate you
being able to do it and desiring to do
it. And I understand the
Yeah. Go ahead.
Do you do you remember my answer to why
that happens? Because you guys can't
dialogue without saying that we're not
Christian. Uh, and basically making it
personal. But I I want I want you to
include my
believe
Protestants are apostate.
Smile. Smile. Smile. Stop talking.
Uh Marlin, before we go, can you take uh
the link that I that I copied here for
my notes so that at least people can
read it for themselves what the notes
are and what my arguments were um going
forward included in the description or
something like that. that way they can
see, you know, unbiased, you know, from
from like uh the argument of the other
side who made it real personal. So,
yeah, I understand. Yeah, I totally I I
will put the link of your resources in
the description. Miles, same thing for
you. If you have any links for resources
that you want people to get to to
connect with, make sure you do that as
well. Make sure you give that to me as
well, so I can actually put that in the
description. And I'll be um I'll be
linking both of you guys YouTube channel
in the description as well so people can
go check you out and and and uh interact
with your your content.
Can I say one thing? Not in arguing like
not an argument.
Yeah. Go ahead,
Keith. Keith, I want to have a dialogue
with you. I asked in your comment
section. I initiated this. I want to
have a dialogue, but I want us to be
honest with one another. Me saying that
I don't think you're a Christian doesn't
mean I want dialogue with you. I got a
little I apologized earlier. I did get a
little worked up. Um, you should
appreciate people being honest with you.
I would want you to be honest with me. I
appreciated when Anthony came on here
the last time I was debating and told me
straight up, "Yeah, you're an apostate
Protestant. I don't think that you're a
Christian." I would sit down with
Anthony again and dialogue for however
long he wanted. I wouldn't yell at him.
I'm not calling him names. I'm just
stating the honest truth. I'm being
honest with you. I do not believe that
somebody that believes that Jesus alone
did not accomplish the atonement is a
Christian. You don't need to be offended
by that. That's just me being honest. We
can have a dialogue on your channel. We
can have a dialogue on my channel. Your
channel is dedicated to Sabbath
apologetics. I'm happy to come on there
and talk about the Sabbath. You can come
on my channel. We can talk about the
Sabbath. Um, don't view it as as name
calling, but bro, come on. Your church
teaches that Protestants are apostates.
So, just be honest about it. I wouldn't
be offended if you told me that. I'd
respect you actually a lot more and say,
"Wow, I'm glad that you actually do.
You're honest about what you truly
believe." I wouldn't be offended by
that. Then, let's sit down and talk
about it. But until we're honest about
these things, we can't have an honest
progressive conversation um and actually
make headway because we're just beating
around the bush on these things. So, I
apologize that I got a little heated
earlier. Um I did uh I'm passionate
about this. I I think that again this is
just a a blasphemous idea and I I I um I
absolutely abhore the idea of my Lord uh
being demeaned that way and the work
that he solely has accomplished being
credited to Satan. So, I'm sorry about
that, but let's continue the dialogue
whether offline or online.
All right. Uh hopefully guys be able to
do it, man. But I got to shut this thing
down, guys. [laughter]
But nonetheless, you guys are great. I
appreciate both of you. And so, um any
closing words before I shut this thing
down?
Keith, it's all yours.
I got nothing.
All right, guys. I'm gonna let you guys
go. You guys take care and hopefully be
speaking to you guys soon. All right.
All right, guys. [snorts and gasps] All
right, man. Another one in the books.
This one's a bit choppy, you know. This
is not necessarily I like smoothness,
you know, on top of the the
miscommunication with the format, you
know. Then my earbuds go out and stuff
and you know it's just this is one of
those shows where you still feel that
you got good content. You know you still
got the good me you got everything you
wanted there but it wasn't smooth. There
was some turbulence there. But
nonetheless, I hope that at the end of
it all, I hope that you guys out there
uh understood what was being said,
understood the arguments, understood the
the conversation that was taking place
and um and
you know, these are one of those things
because there's a lot of with this, you
know, this there's a lot of emotion
here, right? has a lot of emotion within
this debate because these guys, you
know, like I said, um, Miles was
formerly with the Seventh Day Adventist
Church. His father still in the Seventh
Day Adventist Church. Keith is under
the leadership of Miles's father. So, if
you guys can understand the amount of
the the emotional baggage that comes
with this type of conversation. And then
on top of all that obviously which is
most important is salvation you know so
these are things that are all built up
and so you see these type of emotions
come spill out sometimes and I pray that
that didn't take away from the full
understanding of what was being conveyed
in this debate and um I hope you guys
are looking forward to more of these
type of conversations. Uh Ma said
numerous times throughout this
conversation that um he's glad that
these things are being captured. You
know, these things are, you know, what
the Seventh Day Adventists believe is
being captured. Um and I agree. I agree.
And I agree ba on the base fundamental
point of that that's what the gospel
truth is trying to do. Right? This is
what this is what the gospel truth is
trying to The gospel truth is trying to
build a catalog
of different positions, different
theological ideas, different theological
debates, and being able to give these to
the audience, to the believer, right?
For training, for uh being able to
approach an opposing position in a
manner that's respectful and honorable
and glorifying to God, right? So this is
so [snorts] I 100% agree with Miles that
he is glad that this that information of
what Keem Keith was saying was captured
and and this is why you know this
ministry is what it is and I appreciate
these guys coming on and and debating
these subject matters because they're
important things to understand. You
know, once again, 7day Adventist, man,
you don't see them. You don't see them a
lot on these type of platforms. You
don't see Jehovah's Witnesses a lot on
these type of platforms. You don't see
Mormons even on these type of platforms.
And it always bo it bo it it bothers me
one that they're not willing to put
their positions on front street and be
able to go through a critical
examination of what the de what debating
does for you. Um and it also bothers me
that
it it's almost as if these positions
don't want to interact like they're
they're closing themselves in. Um, and I
think that's just 100% totally the wrong
approach, especially when we're dealing
with debates because when we're dealing
with this type of conversation, everyone
believes that their position is the
right position, right? When you go into
a debate, you're believing that your
position is the right position. Okay,
fair enough. And chances are when you
walk away from this debate, even whether
you get quote unquote slaughtered or
whether the debate was a welltoned
debate, whatever it is, you're probably
going to walk away with your position.
You're saying that you're still right in
your position.
Well, that's that's fine. But at the
very least, you can walk away
understanding some things that perhaps
your argument in this position is wrong.
And that's why I wish more Mormons and I
wish more Jehovah's Witnesses and I wish
more Seventh Day Adventists would come
out of the room and debate and argue
these points vigorously
because it not only helps to understand
their position, but it helps to see if
their position is right.
Right. And that's the beautiful thing
about debating. It's the beautiful thing
about debating. You know, I saw I know I
sort of went on a rant there, but I felt
it was necessary to go on a little bit
of rant there, so to speak to uh to sort
of smooth things over cuz this was it
was it was a little rough. It was a
little rough, but I think we did good. I
think we did fine. All right, so I have
a question here. Any updates on the
Rogers and Williams debate? Man,
I know. I just spoke to Will I just text
Williams uh William uh earlier uh he
text me and said that well it was
yesterday night he was texting me and he
said that the um that he just got done
launching his book and apparently that's
what's been the holdup um over the last
couple months is that he's been trying
to I guess finish his book and things
like that. And at least this is what
he's telling me that he's he's you know
he was in the process of finishing his
book and it finally launched uh I think
a day or two ago. And so he said now
that his time is free. So I'm assuming
that now we'll be able to come to an
agreement on a date. Um I know I'm I'm
tired of waiting. Um I really want to
see the debate. uh William and William
and Anthony are very very well very good
debaters, right? And they know their
stuff and from their particular
perspectives and I'm really anxious to
see how they interact. So, um I'm
looking forward to it just as much as
you are.
Um,
and I'm hopefully hopeull hope hopefully
we'll be able to come to a set on a date
and a time and get this thing in the
books and get it done because I know
William has to be tired of it. I know
Anthony is definitely tired of it from
seeking and Anthony and I know I'm
getting exhausted. I'm just trying to
prep trying to make sure it happens and
I don't want to I don't I don't want to
leave it. I don't want to um let it go
by the wayside. I really I really desire
for this debate to happen and I'm
confident that it'll happen. Um I'm
confident that it'll happen. These guys
are uh are professionals,
you know, and what come what what what
comes with professionalism is that we'll
knock this out, you know, and I'm I'm
looking forward to it. I really am. I
really am looking forward to it. So
hopefully that update helps you out. And
I've got an email, too. I'm not sure who
I got an email from, but they asked the
same question like when are we going to
get an update on William and Anthony,
you know, and I'm waiting just like you
guys are, but I am in continuous
communication with those guys and
hopefully it will happen soon. All
right. So, that said, [music]
I'm going to get out of here and I pray
that you guys were blessed by this
debate and I pray that this debate will
be used [music] in future for you guys'
reference and be able to dive into this
stuff. All right, that said, I'm going
to get out of here. May God bless you
and may God keep you.
[music]
Yeah.
Down.